- Put some more in here, it is 2017,
Auntie got time today,
I got time this holiday.
(electronic dance music)
You're 21 now right,
'cause we 'bout to drink.
Don't tell your momma.
(electronic dance music)
You gonna need a new
tablecloth for all the tea
I'm getting ready to spill, I know that.
That's why he can't keep a girl now,
that's why he got three baby mommas,
cause he always out here.
Uh-uh, a little bit more.
Them degrees ain't gonna
keep you warm at night now.
Find yourself somebody on the yard,
preferably not light-skinned,
'cause they don't know how to act.
Me and your daddy never got along.
He used to say I drank too much,
I don't know why he would
ever say I drink too much
and your mother would
agree, my own sister.
- Have you heard of this
new app called The Bible?
(lively choir music)
Here you go, baby.
(wrapping paper crinkles)
- [Niece] Oh great, another Bible.
(choir music continues)
- You're welcome.
Father, God, I thank
you, Jesus, for this food
as it nourishes our souls, our
mind, and our spirits today,
tomorrow, and the day after that, God.
We thank you for your blessings
and for the new Bible my baby got.
- Now I know how Mariah feels.
(classical music)
You know, Winston and I just
got back from Bora Bora.
It was a marvelous time.
Your mother, she's always
been a little envious of me.
And I love her, but it
was never in her cards.
I remember us being three years old
and her picking Rose Art over Crayola.
Who does that?
What's a girl gonna do? (laughs)
You just gotta let go and let God.
(laughs)
- You remember my roommate, Sarah, right?
(hip-hop music)
- Dating, dating anyone?
(laughs)
No, I've been slammed,
between work and school.
I'm getting my third degree, PhD.
I'm focusin' on me right now.
Last month I was actually in Miami.
It was for this weird
thing called Sweet Heat.
It was all females, women empowerment.
I'm really about that, I'm a big feminist.
I met a lot of friends,
got a lot of new friends.
- Oh my god, you are glowing.
Have you been drinking
the kombucha I sent?
(funky music)
I made y'all some brownies.
Your mom used to love these.
Don't tell her I gave you them though.
What do you mean you're out of kale?
What do you have that's locally sourced?
I can't do sugar, I can't do
oil, I can't do seasonings.
Is there anything you guys can
hook up for me in the back?
Okay, ya, you know what,
just bring me a bread basket, thanks.
- [Server] I can do that.
- It feels so good to have money.
Do you see this coat? (laughs)
- I earned this.
- About to get high as fuck.
- No, I need some wine to deal with y'all,
my messy ass sisters, and
their trifling ass husbands.
I can't stand none of them
and their badass kids.
That's why I have kids,
that's what I tell everybody.
You can't drink when you
pregnant and got young children.
No, no.
(bright pop music)